getting more and more excited more and
more excited by us on guarantee more
thing getting more and more excited
about what we got plans with you - they
do right yes there it's going to get
[ __ ] good can garyvee up in the
office do racktrap it will be to
corporation talk about ownership and
leverage tape you fine detective average
[Music]
I gave me something apart they got a
party Lee my name mother the credit kind
of daughters who ever forget it but then
I was like aside I told you are the best
back that underdog Center knitted in bed
I thought December to are anything I
thought it was you are I thought it was
you are like there's just a complete
lack of practicality right now bake on
what I call speak entrepreneurship a
Waterman for most of us
a hundred percent problem is the five or
ten o'clock or whatever
but you see this in like their bubbles I
mean real estate has historically had
these bubbles right and like the people
that know how to navigate them really
could win and that's what's gonna happen
in technology
they'll be these bubbles when the bubble
burst in 2001 and everybody ran to
Investment Banking they should have
tripled down that's where all the wealth
was made worth if you knew right 632 you
knew what you felt like a 25 they're the
same Jews they fired it's real
interesting man you make different
decisions when you have nine years
patients 13 years patients 20 years
patients you say with 77 year old Greeks
who are like right I was right
they saw the pattern he still need you
to say yes you were right doesn't go
right
you know lady rock we're going to look
back at this vlog and like I'm going to
be oldest shits no hair crumply Yoda
looking and I'll be doing the same [ __ ]
I was doing right now it's going to look
exactly the same came up and got a car
yeah please fire all figured I had
enough knowledge ran up a check that I
don't know my yeah everybody's got goes
that everybody's get accomplished I mean
let's be honest I'm a urologist and how
many are me insane wait something we are
on the same page then I make up run a
chance that I dare let's got off the
phone with a nurse sports recruiting
recruiting recruiting not to go on
Instagram live let me give you an update
since it's ready for 14 mountain time
and I actually got a little clip for me
so my morning clean out here to sports
owner conference and number three
expiring assets I am obsessed on how
sports continues to waste their expiring
assets to not have a hardcore team in
place to understand on a
second-by-second minute by minute hour
by hour basis on how many seats are
going to be empty how many spots
misstating to BFD what's happening in
the parking lot this is all sawdust and
can be converted into incredible
business conversion and I highly
recommend you get practical about your
empty whatever in this environment and
more importantly this is an opportunity
for you to act like a media company and
create content for example every
organization excuse the Chiefs I'm
looking at you can literally search
Kansas City on Instagram right now you
can see the top nine people that have
posted a piece of content on Instagram
in the kansas city mile radius you can
literally DM those individuals and
invite them at scale not the one big
celebrity to sit courtside who's on a TV
show the 1400 people that live in the
Kansas City region who are not coming
who are not supporting but you've got
the assets to literally talk to them
one-on-one its business development at
scale and what they give you for return
on an expiring asset is incredible it
doesn't take that much it doesn't take
that much
awesome effort to add five more people
to go on the field prior to the game but
the media that you get in return for
those five posting content to the 30,000
eighty thousand nine hundred thousand
people that follow them is
disproportionate just the networking and
jamming and a lot of good stuff on that
front just running the business from my
my cell phone
meetings and phone calls all afternoon
just a very unusual for me to be in the
same place more than 24 hours but want
to take advantage of Steve Ross being
here we've gotten a lot of quality time
and talking about our macro strategies
of the firm over the next decade and
just meeting a bunch of sports owners
which is always fun um and that's it so
I'm gonna go live right now if you rock
that's what I want to do a little
different kind of setting give you some
different angles deer on its Instagram
live session time why do I do lots
I think it's tremendous engagement and
interaction right you can create a lot
more of a relationship you know
one-on-one like when you know taha and
presented by rel and it's just an
opportunity for me to engage at scale
Instagram lives got a huge audience and
here we are already 1400 people watching
this so you know in a snap it gives me
an opportunity to engage and really I
guess it at the end of the day like it's
just a huge opportunity to just be just
to give back and just for need to core
things that I want to get out of it
alive is a for everybody know how
grateful I am David follow me on
Instagram I think I'm stunned by
people's inability be grateful and
thankful I'm stunned that people take it
for granted the fact that six people
follow you on a social network and want
to see what you have to say should
humble you that six human beings give a
[ __ ] so I want all 1700 of these people
right now to know I give a [ __ ] and I'm
so grateful that they give a [ __ ] about
my content and then number two just
answering [ __ ] right like you know just
you know what to start business in India
that was the question of AJ's call me
god dammit AJ just kill me hey bruh
[Music]
he got planning [ __ ] [ __ ] derailed
trains again back again William you are
first your green buds ah my great green
ear pods are custom Tyler got them
somebody made them not sure how I got
them but I know Tyler asked me do I want
them and I said yes Madalena good to see
you color we're calm that's cool
what's going on everybody a couple
things one if you're not following my
podcast and it's Gary the audio you're
making the great mistake of all time
Gary Vaynerchuk calm has all my events
on it the rock can you go to the events
page and give me some knowledge on wanna
do my first trade show August 19th
Boston we've got Frankfurt Germany
August 31st Frankfurt Germany my
sister's coming to that no map just in
between calls to my room how do I get my
music to you
I think Dee rocks the best way JC world
Oh Dee Rock said yeah maybe or anything
I just really like that anything can
happen at any point and so like you can
either be crippled by that or you can be
empowered by that and so just kind of I
think about it Jed good to see you
you've got to be down on my podcast them
but just gangster [ __ ] on it I'm super
pumped YouTube in September when I was
going to all we have a ridiculous
article coming out Colin I've been
working on a beast about legacy
literally probably the most effort I put
in and you know were distributing it
ridiculously long blog post on Facebook
actually can you call Colin real quick
and ask them when they're coming out I
wanted it for tomorrow that's yes it is
on Spotify it is on Spotify Khan so as
you guys already know I have a speaker
coming out in November I'm very excited
about the Gary B sneaker you know this
is like pretty big good stuff I've got
that video coming out it's with case is
somewhere some case was today I'm
cramping so this is not it
and it's gonna be awesome I hope some of
you rock the Gary bean I cannot wait to
the first person I see at the airport
where my sneaks and the new book
crushing it coming out in January 2018
excited about that oh my god do you hear
about my suitcase oh you know big this
shirt is I couldn't where'd so guys I
literally literally you'll love this
citation cases coming up to Aspen I
literally have no clothes and nothing
like actually packed like a food [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all right just text me
and be rock a place to go bye chef I've
absolutely nothing this is undergoing
the last inspection just needed to bring
like like literally like sandals and
like a hat and like and the other one
had all the stuff and like I was on a
call and like uh you know somebody on my
team like threw the wrong bag in there
so literally showed up here so be Rock
had to go and buy [ __ ] including this
humongous polo doesn't fit all sorts of
weird [ __ ] and like literally I had to
buy underwear like and like socks some
you know like I'm pretty pretty awkward
pretty awkward situation
[Music]
and I'll be taking mine in the message
God we know God to be here Oh kid I'm
gonna put my name in here see me come
[Music]
here yeah do you rock speed it up
you're going to hear nothing one day
hopefully I'll be able to show you that
entire phone call it could end up being
ridiculous
two days in Aspen tons of Steve Ross
time keynote to a bunch of owners from
around all four major sports and then
some little cricket actions for
everybody in that part of the world and
just a ton of phone calls operating
making business decisions staffing
strategies new business strategies new
product offering strategies vaynermedia
pure Wow Vayner X an exciting phone call
that you'll see footage from that secret
that hopefully one day I can release in
the vault whether it happens or not we
will release in seven or eight years you
know we should come up with some timing
on that just thirty productive trip here
to Aspen super excited about it focused
as [ __ ] go get your money on on innocent
so just nobody you can trust will you
not dance there's a lot gonna feel like
we say that every day guys saris are
such limited footage for this episode at
this conference with all the major
sports ownerships and they kind of
kiboshed
the dirac unfortunately but very
productive meetings networking
networking networking reverse-engineer
your finish line I know I want to buy
the Jets York Jets there's any confusion
in my professional life and so even
though I hate spending two days in one
place this is the kind of place I should
be for that game and so whatever you
want in life you know second home ten
trillion dollar of franchise just to fix
your parents business make that line and
work backwards and make every decision
map to that that's what these next two
days are about given time until Miami
see me come on naughty father I'm here
I'm just glad to be here yes unscarred
to be here guys thank you so much
so much for supporting my youtube
channel please subscribe if this is your
first time or if you've been watching
and you haven't [ __ ] subscribed